how committed am i to what i say i want
and because at the end of the day the if
you don't believe it no one else will
what's your writing process i work five
days a week minimally sometimes six
sometimes seven but i prefer not to
i'm
always
thinking about a story or
there's always something going on here
in my head i don't have regular writing
hours at various times i have but now
because i'm writing and producing and
directing and doing books as well
um my day is split up into smaller
chunks and i'm often doing
many different tasks in a given day
uh because i have full-time editor
full-time um you know
line producer vfx team all of that
um
uh so
when i sit down to write i try to write
for several hours minimally i
but i but it's like you know i but i can
also write on the fly if i need to i can
write almost anywhere i can write in a
moving car i've written in jeeps
traveling through the jungle in thailand
when i did a pilot for nbc that was shot
there i mean
it's like
i
i'm often working on several scripts
simultaneously um i'm always reading
several books uh at the same time and
then i'll come up with ideas and i'll
jot them down i'll save those and
sometimes i'll i'll um
i'll write them or i won't i mean one of
the ideas i came up with recently that i
liked was um well two two i came up with
that i liked one was
um i heard about the slave revolt in
haiti
where they actually succeeded you know
in freeing themselves and i thought what
would have happened if before the civil
war that it happened in america that had
spread to america and then now it's the
modern day and there's a separate
country of free of of the descendants of
freed black slaves so the south it's
like it's not the confederacy one that
won the civil war and we've got two
americas it's that there's a black
nation where those slaves freed
themselves and what would that look like
and what would our country look like and
that was an interesting idea and another
idea i came up with which was rather
amusing was just a short story where
someone would have the chance to go back
in time one time and there's an artist
who never got his due was never
recognized for his talent and died
without knowing that anyone would would
you know cared about his art he'd been
rejected a lot during his lifetime so he
goes back and convinces the official um
art
authorities to like take him in and
accept him and do
shows of his paintings and so forth and
the way it would be structure is we
would believe throughout the story that
it's vincent van gogh but in the end
it's adolf hitler because if hitler had
succeeded as an artist right he never
would have gone into politics he
wouldn't have there'd be no nazi party
none of that and so it just it just
struck me as a funny story that that
hitler had he just been appreciated for
his artwork
it would have really changed that
century so it was just but again so i
come up with many many ideas like for
instance when i mentioned sitting down
to come up with 200 ideas there's
actually up to 300 now ideas for movies
or tv shows where i just jot them down
and
and um
and sometimes i'll i'll i'll pursue them
it varies there are certain ideas that i
definitely will write like with space
command i knew i was going to do that
and i knew that i would write the entire
season which which i have um and then
we'd shoot it so um
but
i'm always
working on something i'm never lying
fallow um
and
some scripts it's like
like over the next few months we'll be
rewriting this the final six hours of
season one of space command but meantime
i plan to write you know i mean
we're also gonna write and shoot all all
the other five pilots of the show
runners network um you know and so
that's so we've written sweethaven now
and again it's always just
who are the characters what is the idea
how does this move how does this grow
what is it saying you know but it's
always through characters i mean it's
you know with with sweetheaven part of
the genesis that was my friend michael
harney he's in project blue book he's in
orange is the new black he's in um for
all mankind
and yet he never gets these wonderful
lead roles that he should and so i said
well how would you like to play a cop
and be the lead in sweethaven where all
the people under 60 die and but i also
created his brother who will also be
playing who went the exact opposite path
and is very s
dangerous
and i thought that would be fun too
because i have my physical trainer who
i've been with for 30 years elaine and i
both um he had an identical twin brother
who was very very different from him and
so that became of interest to me so it
isn't just using a cliche from soap
operas you know of the twins the good
twin and the bad twin it's just the
interesting thing of someone who goes
very different from someone who looks
like him you know it's just fun
and and then you know so it's but um but
any given week i'm writing i'm
you know working in my producer capacity
so i'll be meeting with my vfx team and
reviewing vfx shots i'll be marketing
i'll be doing the mr sci-fi stuff i'll
be building my audience it's all part of
the job you know it's all you know i am
you know in directing i mean today we
were just you know getting the sets
ready to get them get them up and
running you know so it's exciting it's
fun
when you were writing in the jeep uh
through the jungles of uh
oh you were typing yeah i can type in a
moving vehicle and so this wasn't on
like a legal pad you were actually okay
yeah yeah i can write it on on a legal
pad but but it's easier to type in a
moving vehicle um because when you're
jostled and you're trying to write it
you kind of you know do that but um
but i'm very fortunate i think it's
because when i was a kid i read books my
mom would have me in the back seat and i
would read voraciously and i think the
fact that i
did that all you know kind of meant that
i'm not i don't get carsick and so um
so yeah and and often i've had to write
um under deadline in those kind of
circumstances i can write with music
playing i mean i can be in like a busy
coffee shop or something and i'm not
distracted
so um
you know i just go into that world you
know and uh you know so it's very fun
how did you figure out your writing
process
well
um
in television you have deadlines and so
you just have to get very you write very
fast you'll have maybe a week or two to
write an entire script the hardest
i have i ever had the hardest experience
was i had to write two hour scripts in
one week for two different series there
was one period of three months where i
was writing i think nine scripts for six
different shows
and
and i could juggle between outlining i'd
be outlining one while writing the
script for another but there were two
shows they would not budge on the
deadline and so the way i did that was
i would write 10 pages of one in the
morning have lunch to clear my head then
write 10 pages of the other one in the
afternoon and i did that for six days
straight so at the end of six days i had
two 60 page scripts and one was forever
night and the other was space precinct
and they both got shot they both got
made
and um
and then another time i wrote 55 pages
in one day
which was for uh i think an animated
show called black star and elaine was a
faster typist that was back when we were
on typewriters and so i was writing the
pages freehand and handing them to a
lane she was typing and at the end of
the day i had the entire script written
so and that got made too of course and
so there there's something there's a
very different energy where you know
that everything you write will get made
it's it's then it becomes very pragmatic
it's not like you you know you don't you
don't wait for inspiration you put in
the work you just you know it's like if
i have to write an entire script over a
weekend i can i will i prefer not to
you know but um but i find that
qualitatively there are scripts that
i've written in a week that were every
bit as good as scripts that took me a
year
and you know so i'm
you know it's i'm i i have faith in my
abilities after all this time i know
what i can do
um
though
you have to know
the story you're telling
because
you can't afford to get lost in your
script it can't go south you have to
know that's why outlining particularly
in tv is so important because you have
to know
what what the structure is what how it
tracks that doesn't mean you can't um
depart from that if you know you're
going somewhere better but you just
can't there's not a lot of room for that
wild experimentation you know so
but um but but usually i find that i'm
my i'm clearest in terms of my writing
in the afternoons so i'll usually write
in the afternoons but
i can write any time that i need to
write you know if i'm under the gun
and uh
i remember one time when we were
shooting the first hour of space command
bob picardo mentioned that i'd
referenced
the wizard of oz in an early scene that
he had with doug jones but i didn't pay
it off and so we were going to be
shooting
that like a few days later and i woke up
in the morning
with the entire scene in my head
that paid off the wizard was and so
while so i said to elaine you drive and
so while we were driving to the studio i
typed the scene and then when we got to
the studio i went to the office and said
print this out then i gave it to doug
and to bob and that that day we shot it
so but that was because bob was right he
had a great um note and but it was just
like but that's how sometimes the
process is like that
um other times you know it's uh other
times you'll have to go through draft
after draft after draft and uh and
hopefully find find your way you know
but but tv has a much shorter um
uh
you know runway so you better be able to
take flight when you run out of you know
the the landing strip you know it's you
you better be able to hit the air and uh
i but that's why but i love the speed of
television and i love the fact that most
the what what you write gets made you
know it's uh i never could have had a
happy life as a screenwriter i don't
think that would have been for me at all
well that was my next question is what
would your advice be to someone who
doesn't have the advantage of a deadline
they are their own deadline yes and and
they are their own audience for a while
work with a timer that's what i do
um we all have timers in our in our
phones so
say okay i'm going to write you have to
write on a regular basis you have to
have a discipline
and it's not so if you say
um
my writing hours are going to be from
9 a.m to 12
you know noon
and and you find a space where you're
not going to get distracted
you find a writing space it could be at
a starbucks it could be a corner of your
home it doesn't matter where it is but
that's your writing place and people
know it's your writing place and they
know that your time that's your writing
time and it's sacrosanct you don't do
other stuff in that in those hours and
you set your alarm for three hours or
two hours or one hour whatever it is and
you sit there and even if nothing comes
you sit there you do the work and um and
you treat it just like a job just like
if you were working at a shoe store you
know you're working for yourself
but you cannot just watch tv you cannot
go you know
you know talk with your pals no you're a
writer and
uh but also setting a deadline for when
a draft will be done is very important
so you just say okay uh three weeks from
now i'm going to have a draft written it
doesn't have to be good it just has to
be
this beginning middle and end and then
you can go back and revise but just you
just you go you know and if and
but
professional writers need to treat it
like a job the best schedule of anyone i
ever knew was ray bradbury he would
write five days a week he would get up
in the morning right um until lunchtime
then he would have lunch then he would
take a nap and in the afternoon he would
attend to business
and then evenings and weekends were for
the family and he did that for over 70
years
so pretty phenomenal well these
wonderful things that we have in our
pockets to shoot film also are a
distraction and now we can check news
and now everything that we're interested
in is now going to be reflected back
over and over again and you have to be
careful i mean again you can
lose yourself
in all of these pursuits but ultimately
at the end of the day it's like
how committed i am to say
how committed am i to what i say i want
and because at the end of the day the if
you don't believe it no one else will
and the only way they can believe it is
if you get things finished if you get
things out there if you
i
you know i mean nobody ever says i want
to be a brain surgeon but i want it to
be really easy you know if they know
that you you've put in work you know
it's like and but but people think that
writing's going to be easy it's not some
days it's easy some days it's hard but
fortunately
if you're doing it right the audience
can't tell what was hard and what was
easy which is fun which is really fun um
when it's easy when it's good
and and it comes easily it is good you
know i'm not deluding myself when it's
hard though
i can struggle and struggle and if i
nail it ultimately
the audience has no idea that was
difficult it flows you know so that's a
relief
so uh but
you know it's
but you know it's
the script is just the blueprint the
script is just the arrow pointing the
way you know i i don't
i mean for instance i have to decide
like today we were having an actress try
on one of the costumes to see if it
worked we were deciding if she would be
on a bed in this hospital room or if she
would be in like this this um you know
cylinder thing uh that would be like
with tubes plugged in and things and
computer panels and stuff and so it's
like that's part of the writing process
too uh determining what the lighting is
going to be is it going to be subdued is
it going to be bright what color is it
going to be what lens are we going to be
using these are all creative decisions
um
you know i've been acquiring uh like i
own i think 14 or 15 spacesuits now you
know so i acquire them from different
productions or my mom got me one when i
was a kid and um
and then you redress them i get sets
from the best place to get sets from is
uh
big budget science fiction movies that
tanked because no one saw them and the
production design is great and then you
you redress them so they're yours but it
gives you this level of
um just artistry and and detail and they
because they put so much money into it
so you um so that's and that's a trick i
learned from rod sterling because when
he shot twilight zone at mgm he used
every prop and costume and set that they
had you know
and when i was a producer at sliders on
sliders at universal i said can i use
everything from every universal
production ever made and they said huh
no one's ever asked that let me find out
and they came back and they said with a
very few exceptions yes and we were
using stuff from jurassic park and time
cop and 12 monkeys and on and on it was
fabulous uh the best little whorehouse
in texas we shot one of our episodes in
that house
so uh but you know it's um
i'm in the business of being
ingenious
and so the more i come up the more i
pull a rabbit from a hat the more that i
come up with a clever idea the more i
say okay this is
this is the way to get where we're going
it's a series of problems that need to
be solved but it's a joyous process and
i mean to take something that's just in
your head and put out in the world so
everyone can see it it's just
it's just there's no there's nothing
like it it's wonderful when it comes
together it's great you know i uh i love
that process and i feel part of a
tradition i feel in a way that rod
sterling and harlan nelson and all these
wonderful people who uh inspired and and
guided me i'm part of that tradition the
reason i like to mentor people
is because
i feel that i can then pass on what i've
learned from from these amazing people
and uh
it doesn't end with me
i'm just part of the part of the process
part of the flow
have you ever mentored someone or met
someone that you could just tell they
weren't going to be teachable
yes i have and uh
and the lovely thing is i don't ever
assume that i have to succeed with
anybody
like one of the rules of my round table
when i started was there's no any
everyone is welcome if they come with a
good heart there's no decision as to
who's deserving notice no decision as to
who has talent or who's going to make it
or not if someone comes with a good
heart
writers producers actors directors
editors composers anybody they're
welcome because we're creating a
community a supportive community um when
i mentor people if they're just not
going to get it i just stop talking
because it's sort of like you know this
when they'll say well this is what i'm
going to do and i'll say well that's
probably not going to work
you know i don't and i'm not usually not
that blunt but i'll say well you know
here's a few other ideas that would i
think be easier
to make happen and if they just are
resistant to that they say okay well go
with god and also if they come back and
say i did that and it worked i'll say
great you know because again i don't
need
to have there's no there's no one way to
do it there's a lot of ways to fail of
course you know giving up is a
really bad idea because when you give up
it guarantees that nothing's going to
happen
but if but you can't just keep failing
and failing and failing you figure out
what's going wrong some people can't
write and if you can't write but you
want to make film or make tv then
they'll affiliate with someone who's got
the talents you don't have and do what
you can do do what you're good at
some people for instance guillermo del
toro told me he's not great with
dialogue so he you know he's good with
plot good with imagery my god but so he
affiliates with people who write
dialogue well um
you know you find the person like when i
mentioned earlier that i direct with
elaine
could i learn the skills that elaine has
to work with direct with actors yes i
could i could learn those skills and i'm
not terrible i mean i can i can work
with actors i do know what the what the
through line emotionally is and so forth
but but elaine having been an actor and
gone to drama school and
directed off broadway she has a depth of
uh she has a bag of tricks that i don't
have but but because i'm collaborating
with her i don't have to learn that
stuff because she has it so i can say
well
how do we get this how do we get this
effect how do we get this actor to do
this thing and she'll then talk to them
and it's like wow great you know so um
and sometimes it's miraculous to me like
it's like how did you do that
so good you know and uh so that's that's
really fun but on the other hand i had
to teach her to like not think of it
like directing a play it's like look at
the monitor see there that angle is not
a good angle
so like turn them this way
you know and now now she's much more
savvy to camera angles and all that kind
of stuff so we we learn from each other